[Musique]
le conseil départemental s'engage dans
la lutte contre les troubles causés par
l'alcoolisation foetale par la signature
d'une charte de prévention des
professionnels de l'accompagnement
social des acteurs de la santé et le
président de l'association sa france ont
présenté cette charte
déjà signée par des experts de 35 pays
sur ce problème de santé publique
mondial
cette convention est l'engagement du
département dans la prévention et la
lutte du saf et actes ce travail
partenarial que nous devons mener pour
lutter efficacement contre ce fléau
montrant cette convention réunionnaise
et ça m'a donné l'idée de faire la même
chose sur le reste de la métropole
sur le reste des départements
ultramarins naturellement donc on va
faire part de cette expérience à tous
les départements français de l'ain
puisse s'y associer s'ils le souhaitent
à la réunion tous les deux jours un
enfant né avec des troubles causés par
l'alcoolisation foetale
si des signes physiques ne permettent
pas d'identifier les symptômes les
troubles mentaux engendre des
difficultés cognitives et d'inadaptation
sociale comme en témoigne cette mère et
son fils victime d'alcoolisation foetale
beaucoup de l'école elle a beaucoup de
retard et la difficulté si dans la vie
de tous les jours comme emilie est
victime de ça même il a beaucoup troublé
de la tête tu es là beaucoup de lapins
logique et de la vie actuelle d'ol
travail ouais et pour la première fois
dans la lutte contre l'alcoolisation
foetale sera lancée à la réunion le
savent ton les 8 et 9 septembre prochain
il sera possible de faire des dons aux
32 20 une mobilisation qui se fera
depuis la réunion et qui sera aussi
accessible pour la métropole et
l'ensemble des doigts et le savent ton
que nous lançons qui est un mouvement de
solidarité nationale régionale et
internationale par de la réunion la
région devient un trait d'union pour
cette prévention à l'échelle mondiale
dès la première année nous sommes
convaincus que les réunionnais vont
participer à cet élan de solidarité ça
permettra de prendre conscience que ce
problème est évitable que on s'attaque
réellement aux racines des addictions
on s'attaque à aux racines de l'échec
scolaire aux racines de la délinquance
que l'alcoolisation prénatal résume en
fait une cause qui a à voir avec tout
ces problèmes de société
[Musique]